katy nous a ramené un chien de la
fourrière elle dit que c'est mon mon
frère seulement moi je veux pas de frère
et j'ai même pu donner maintenant je
dors par terre comme un chien pourquoi
qui m'a fait ça parce que tu as cathy à
mes chiens et donc elle est complètement
bizarre totalement irrationnel takavoir
alain chiant le dash
or je t'en prie tu vas pas commencer et
chloé ce que je voudrais c'est que tu
m'aides mac ça va tu ton ami ok et en
tant qu'ami je vais être franche avec
toi je me fiche pas mal de tes problèmes
en revanche si tu fais rien pour
rétablir la situation
ta petite vie tranquille avec humaine
risque fort d'être sans espoir sans
espoir sans espoir c'est ce que j'ai
mais c'est quoi cette souris sur ma page
encore